[Music]
in say one new submitted by a visionary
waiting for baby boo oh you are ma the
Bell you'll have to feel embarrassed
about that that is crazy not the only
one that happened to having a scene
greener Thank You Belle it's not like
how you when you try to be choice with a
belt only bear with other
yeah like bear oh look I'm scared of it
I know you are
bill Guardian planning to teach young
people how to avoid sexual it's sort a
soul charge shuts off I'm so sorry
so not that song that's all charges how
to get away with radio that cannot be
real are you [ __ ] kidding like the
what mr. juice trying to bring on a book
about how it was like if I did it this
is what I would have done type of [ __ ]
she was gonna bring out a book and it
got cancelled well that one kind of
makes more sense because at least that's
like saying to people that I didn't do
it good if I did exactly but this is
like I did it let me tell you how to
dodge maybe it's a comedic thing he's
like trying to fool people straight up
you're gonna be touring township halls
and people want to watch this using any
request supposedly it's just going to be
sexual assailants like oh well that
makes sense I mean if you if you
sexually tell someone you want to find
out how to jump a tunnel that's smart
so the police made him do this it's not
really his idea so when he hosts these
things all his attendees are going to
get [ __ ] arrest oh my god that's my
book I have to think that Bill Cosby is
doing this for the right reasons and
he's doing something in Oh cut it out
he's a trash one look like Joe would say
he's a garbage can
I know but see it's it's it's a I'm not
saying he's a dope person but I am going
to say this though just because he's a
piece of [ __ ] garbage that probably
should die for the bad things he did if
he did do it doesn't change the fact to
be affected my life in a positive way
we're not talking about every another
I know that's one thing it's not if you
did do it he did you know what for all
the positive positivity that he did do
like maybe one rape is oh no they should
follow the special did you see that yes
oh oh my god it's not about like them
it's a superhero that games take Harley
my snapping like vagina
haha so technically he's raping all
these people in Oh sometimes a superhero
but in order to rape I mean no it's the
same rule you have to rape people we
have to have a sex with them but of
course aren't going to believe him then
he ends up raping them yeah exactly so
he saves more than he rapes yeah that's
what they said about design yes
I'm not saying that what I'm saying is
that he affected my life in a very
positive way however what I am saying is
that's why I'm kind of hope that he's
doing this to catch other rapists
Yeah right you piece of [ __ ] nobody is
totally good or bad everyone's kind of
[ __ ] up in fact yeah but you like
helping people avoid sexual assault
charges is kind of like a different
level it just sounds so fake that's why
I'm saying yeah it does it sounds wrong
before charges it would make sense any
of the charges [ __ ] McLean that's why
I was like reading it to not like
assault is I mean charges on the
different line is it maybe like
separated but the point that I'm trying
to make you know yeah so I feel like
this is his thing he's like he's
sticking to his not guilty right and
then he goes oh and by the way if you
guys don't want to end up like me with
all these false accusations that let me
tell you call his 312 X's but everything
concluded that he's not guilty
so they hadn't had a mistrial because
nobody could have come to a conclusion
so he's not they petitioned to get
another one so he's gonna go back to
court so within the next four months
they're gonna he's going to go back to
work well so how can you even write this
thing because he doesn't even know if
he's technically avoided the charges
he's old as [ __ ] to you because you're
senile at this point man know his rep he
ended up saying quote this is bigger
than Bill Cosby this issue can affect
any young person especially young
athletes us today and they need to know
what they're facing when they're hanging
out and partying when they're doing
certain things that they shouldn't be
doing it
so effect marry month laws are changing
in the statute of limitations for
victims of sexual assault are being
extended so this is why people need to
be educated on a brush against the
shoulder anything at this point can be
considered sexual assault it's a good
thing to be educated about the lawn I
mean I kind of agree but also at the
same time like it's pretty general if
you don't screw somebody it didn't want
to be screwed I think it's because there
are certain guys that are kind of
[ __ ] dumb when it comes to getting
the point and they're just like they
kind of like overstep their boundaries
with women and then you know you're kind
of like pushing off the blame like oh if
I do this that's sexual assault yeah I
think about you Sam about the laws of
like oh you know just prevent getting
any charges against you if you
accidentally like if they're talking
about like if they're in a baseball game
and you know you have to like a shimmy
through the aisle or whatever you
accidentally don't keep her hands in
front of you in a circular motion when
there's girls coming up circular motion
don't don't do this in a crowd okay
don't walk the range like this don't do
this either oh yes he was gonna be
saying at these free attention meaning
protected so like when I saw his
headline all like wait what time well
it's like literally saying how to get
away with rape
you know it sucks to like even looking
at Bill Cosby he looks and he speaks now
he looks like he liked arranged like he
had a little bit of dementia I can't see
kind of lost it a little bit makes me a
mossad I feel like but he's a rapist on
my field he did it because we heard of
people that knew him and a long time ago
that was assaulted by him but that's all
here safe still I don't know so many
victims like a victim or but then
sometimes like when you hear this stuff
then everyone just wants to jump on it
like oh me too me too I got read by him
yeah he [ __ ] crawled through this TV
[ __ ] me in a butthole yeah dude that's
true because one time when Tiger Woods
remember when he got in folios [ __ ]
all those hookers and all these women
started popping up I put him in that -
how do you pronounce it
you know perhaps I was like oh there's
ah the lineup a woman in my face with at
the end he called me a little dumpling
haha [ __ ] yeah well but the thing
that's different to like these guys had
at least proof
you know like will not prove but like
witnesses and stuff it's I don't know
what stuff like that like it does it is
kind of like you never really know
what's going on but if other people also
saw it as well and maybe they're not off
face you know don't do this is just like
the job for agents like when you become
like a pro athlete or you land your big
movie like your agent will tell you
hearing all these parties is going to be
girls are kind of other matters or
trying to get impregnated by you I'd be
careful like these are the things that
you should be doing and not do I know
boo guys are dumb excuse me I just
called it a [ __ ] power
yeah I know throwing themselves at you
saying like here's my house key come
over gradually be relocated every oh
call Paula well how hot would the girl
be though lor you know
yeah because sometimes if a girl just
kind of just almost died I don't know
what do it you know and it's kind of hot
dude yeah do you know what they're doing
I look at them and say you Paula got
AIDS who how many celebrities have you
[ __ ] you you're really that strong yes
only [ __ ] the ones that are ugly but you
gotta love feels nails like so though
I'm sure the ugly ones I've asked you
know just kidding okay that's okay
okay why you why I think I got a
girlfriend I trying to get a [ __ ] you
guys crazy
we gotta keep in mind these are pros
these girls do this [ __ ] for a living
we go to traveling you're getting
constant [ __ ] throwing it like like I
think who said that [ __ ] Eddie Murphy
says you have so much [ __ ] that you
keep putting your pocket is just like
overflowing and it's all to the floor
like that's my [ __ ] here
they're never going to jack me off
harder than I do
ever yeah but they have a [ __ ]
something you don't yeah but I have a
girlfriend he's protected he has a
girlfriend no I say you know what I'm
gonna [ __ ] nut before I go on the show
it's all good you know what make someone
actually said that as I read this they
should just say I'm a create this
invention is for pro basketball players
so after a game and whatever whatnot
they have to go to the hotel and it's
try submit yeah until the morning effect
well that's the masturbation thing they
have that oh yes there's like a [ __ ]
cross where they got a sweep like this
for the hello.c perfect they just give
to them to like I want to [ __ ] these
[ __ ] but I can't
well wouldn't you just want to do it
more once you're out like I had like
five minutes yeah but it's during the
daytime now so everybody sees you that's
true I don't want those [ __ ] are
asleep they don't laughter in the day
but mine will be this it's the crucifix
right but there's a motorized pocket
[ __ ] that Jack Anderson oh I would
break out of this but my strength is
gone so much he does good know what I'm
saying is that it was like someone
forgot what could the Sun be like it
said of before doing something bad
masturbate cuz like apparently I don't
know it's just one of the guys yeah that
should be hard I think I just calms down
if you want to steal something to jack
off anybody now you're not really
feeling feeling anyone go [ __ ] someone
up and like [ __ ] it I don't care I'm
pretty sure if you masturbate to it like
guys if ladies if you don't know after
we masturbate we're [ __ ] geniuses
we're small windows Virginia small
window our IQ goes up like e equals
mc-squared
how do you think [ __ ] just take them
started no got their masturbation and
Joe's like ah I know how that work oh
that's me no that's when you double
dutch brother have another created
colleague but they both jacked off in
separate rooms in the same house oh we
watched him at the same time
they jacked off at the same time and
they're hurting to the scream just hear
like fun
I doubt that's true you told him the
story when you come it I can see clearly
God Judy that's like cause behind all
that [ __ ] he has to declare is mine I
heard that back in those days
celebrities were untouchable and there
was no social media there was no things
like that there was no whistleblowing
and Hollywood was a place of very very
very dark times although that tells me
is that super celebrities and all that
stuff can get away with a lot of bad
things because you know these guys are
making so much [ __ ] money for the
studio's they're going to keep them
protected I wouldn't be surprised if
they're like hey how many did you rate
today bill say I just had three three
you sure you know what for we'll get you
a person you can rape I have the one -
um yeah I don't know I'm just I'm just
making stories up but I'm sure about
those child actors to others they got
webbing named like that they're
protected by the industry but now it
might be different well I mean who knows
because I'm even like Justin Bieber who
knows like in like 20 years how many
girls will come on be like he raped me
poor he baby she got raped because he
started up extra young
yeah maybe that's his legend job Amanda
fires like Justin Bieber I called it
yeah it was reversible and of mine dude
I don't like the dominatrix but
sometimes they'll reverse gangbangs I'm
just like woo hmm when it's all girls in
one guy I don't know their gang banging
him know where you know hello everybody
if you liked the video make sure that
you guys leave us a thumbs up because if
not I'm gonna find you where you live
and I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you
what the you different not other than
that you know it's like more videos up
there bro
[Music]